[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
show people how to build wealth how to
do work that they love and how to create
actual amazing relationships like I have
here with my buddy George camel with the
K I'm your other host Jade warshaw hey
give us a call the number is 8825 5225
we'd be happy to take your call and talk
about the things that are concerning you
uh in your life and in your money and as
a matter of fact we're taking that to
the next level today George after the
Ramsay show after the 3 hours of Ramsay
show we are going to do a live segment
George and I live Q&A here on the
YouTube channel where we're going to
answer all of your budgeting questions
and we're actually going to have the
best app in the world every dollar the
best budgeting app pulled up on the
screen you'll be able to see it kind of
you'll be able to see the whole every
dollar screen and you'll be able to see
George and I and you can actually come
in with your questions you can put your
questions in the chat we'll also be
taking calls so it's kind of like a
bonus ramsy show exclusive to YouTube
yes that's pretty cool we've never done
anything like that yeah so watch on
YouTube because obviously that's where
it's that's where it is like don't be on
your podcast app yes and if you go to
the Ramy Show YouTube channel hit the
notify me button so that you don't miss
it that's right and so today today's
Tuesday January 30th for those listening
it's right after the show so it's 5:00 P
PM Central that's our time 6 Eastern
that's right and if you're in mountain
time you have to do that mouth on your
own figure out figure it out PT we're
not doing all the work for you that's
right we'll do the every dollar work for
you how about that we're going to have
it all pulled up you'll be able to ask
like detailed questions like Jade George
how do I go in there and make a fund or
how do I you know do a long-term
planning on using the fin Financial road
map so we'll be able to help you with
all of those questions and you know if
you just have kind of basic questions
this is not the time to call in and ask
about investing yes we want it to be
focused on budgeting and we'll try to
show you tactically what that looks like
in the every dollar budget to make it
even more tactical that's right we're
all about solving problems George I love
it what we do all right let's go to the
phone lines and help solve Jennifer's
problem in New Jersey what's going on
Jennifer oh hi thanks for taking my call
I'm a huge fan of your show and I I
really appreciate you taking the time to
speak with me today absolutely um yeah
so I just basically in a nutshell I'm
trying to determine if it makes sense
for me to purchase a home or uh continue
to rent for a couple of years and just
briefly my background is I just sold my
home um I'm currently debt free um I'm
55 years old I'm kind of late in the
investment game as far as like 401k and
stuff like that but since I sold my
house I recently contributing now I'm
contributing about 13% of my grow
um I've got about 200,000 in the bank
okay and um in order to purchase a home
around here you were looking at probably
around
300,000 um and my plan was to put
$150,000 down take out 150,000 mortgage
but then I'm kind of um going I feel
like I'm going backwards because now I'm
completely debt free and I'm renting and
but the rent is about $2,000 a month so
I'm not quite sure like I've never been
in this position before where I don't
have any debt I have money in the bank
and I'm secure and so guys take you took
the money from your home sale to pay off
the
debt yeah there wasn't I didn't have
much debt like I'm not a CR I didn't
really have credit cards it was just one
student loan that was about
10,000 um and so there everything and I
don't have any credit cards or car
payments or anything like that so it
really I didn't have much net debt to
begin with but the home was sucking me
dry it was um HOA fees and taxes and it
just it wasn't financially VI viable for
me to just continue to live there I mean
I what did it bring when you sold it I'm
sorry what did it bring when you sold
that house it uh it was it brought about
430,000 but then they had to take out
the realtor fees and stuff like that so
um I took home about 220 okay wow that's
a lot of Fe really yeah yeah it it was
it was a nice it was a nice
um wait a second you said it brought 430
and you brought home 220 how did they
take
half well I had actually I kind of left
out I did have a home equity line of
credit on there that I took out yeah I
help with some schooling schooling for
my kids so let that be a lesson to the
folks listening that when you take at
home equity lines of credit you have to
pay it when you go to sell your house so
it eats up your Equity she should have
had $430,000 of equity in her home and
went away with half of that so that's a
lesson to all of us so you've got
$220,000 you are looking to buy a house
um you're thinking of doing a $300,000
house with $150 down my question to you
would be why wouldn't you just put the
220 down and put as much down as
possible actually yeah I actually have
about 200,000 um does that include your
emergency
fund that's everything that's everything
so so that's why I wanted to keep 50,000
you know kind of in a pocket somewhere
which I again I've never had before got
it but I'm just trying to um you know
I'm trying to determine what makes the
most sense like do I continue to to I
feel like every month that I write write
the rent check out it's like I'm I'm
taking a step backwards but at the same
time there's not much inventory if you
put 15 down on a $300,000 house which is
what you said you wanted are you able to
afford the monthly payment it it would
be on a 15E fixed with I I estimated
taxes and homeowners and it would be
roughly about 1,900 a mon month okay
which is less than what you're paying
now I Which is less than what I'm paying
now but my gross income for yearly gross
income is about
67,000 okay um and I also have a side
business that brings in about um on a
good you know good month it's maybe $800
a month net so how much how much a month
do you see in your hand before before
you take out your
investing before um as far as like well
they already withdraw stuff from my from
my they just started like literally when
I sold the house in in November they
just started taking that out so so what
I'm getting to is we want your payment
to be no more than 25% of your take-home
pay so that's why I'm like what you take
home after taxes but before investing
and before insurance comes out right
because we really just want to see what
it is after taxes your take if your take
home pay is like if if it's going to be
four grand and your payment's two grand
that's a lot of Your World getting
sucked into that house and you're not
going to have enough money to invest
that's where Jade's here and so you may
need to rent months stack up some more
money and then pull the trigger but
you're really close to making this
decision the right way yeah it's it's
close like you guys are pretty much dead
on it you know be roughly like n it's
like uh just about $4,000 a month that's
coming home so that would be like 50% of
my and that's after you're investing
though right that's after investing yeah
and that's and and now since my rent is
2,000 you know I try to weigh out like
okay do I bite the bullet and try and
find something but I just I wanted to
get you see a different perspective like
of what I could do if I decided to just
hang tight and rent for a couple of
years and and you know well the big
question is the big question is do you
see a path for your income to go up in
the next 2 to 5 years that's a question
you've got to ask yourself how long
would it take you to save then the
amount of money that you feel like you
need to get a payment closer to what
you're looking for 25 25% is what we aim
for if you're at 28 or 27 you know
nothing's going to happen to you you're
not going to combust into flames but um
that's what we're looking for and just
make sure that when you guys are doing
this math you're looking at it just at
your take-home pay don't look at it
after your pay after insurance after
investing because you've already whittel
it down with things that are part of
your budget so that's the way this works
25% of your take-home pay is what we're
looking for when we're buying house this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
a debt settlement company and they're
not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
Jade warshaw your host next to me is
George camel with a K don't get it
twisted trust me he gets very angry he
gets very angry if you get it wrong
we're taking your calls all hour so give
us a call the number is 88255 22 5 and
let us know what's going on let's go
straight to the phone lines where we've
got Charlie in my state Orlando what's
going on Orlando Florida what's going on
Charlie hey guys thanks for taking my
call um I'm going through a divorce
right now um and uh I we sold the house
and split the proceeds
50/50 um I was able to use some of that
money to uh pay down my my debts um paid
off my car paid off some credit card
stuff um and the only thing I have left
is uh student loans which are quite
significant um it total about
183,000 um I have one one of those is is
about a $99,000 loan and then the other
the rest is all one big Loan Federal
Loan okay and uh and so I guess my
question is um this is kind of a the
balance of something that would kind of
resemble a mortgage payment in a way and
so I wonder do I treat it like an a
mortgage and um get my three to six
months of uh emergency fund funded
before I start tackling that or um um
how should I go about that listen I'm
I'm empathizing with you because I know
how that feels um my husband and I had
280,000 of student loans and so I I when
you said should we treat it like a
mortgage we used to call our student
loan it's listen it's our mortgage
however it didn't change the way that we
attacked it cuz technically it is still
part of your debt snowball and it can
feel daunting to think okay
I do baby step one I've got $1,000 saved
and you want me to have $1,000 saved for
the duration that it will take to pay
off this loan and I feel that um and the
answer honestly is yes so my question my
next question to you would be how much a
month are you putting on this loan if
you you know this is your only debt how
much a month are you paying towards it
at this point um so so far I've still
been just hitting the minimums um I'm
still kind of sorting out my budget you
know still rusting after you know
splitting with my ex um and so um
there's I don't have a ton of margin in
my in my budget there are things I'm
working on cutting out and and what's
the minimum payments yeah what are the
minimums um it's about total about 300
the the smaller one is around 111 and
the other one is uh around 222 it's in
like an income driven repayment oh now
and what's the interest
rate uh the smaller one is around 11%
and the larger one is uh around nine I
believe goodness gracious so this loan
is ballooning every day yeah yeah cuz
you're not even you're probably barely
even meet meeting the interest if that
yeah matter of fact I'm just I'm just
throwing this in a calculator right now
so you can kind of see so I can kind of
see where you would be
um yeah that's one of the things I hate
most about the income driven repayment
plans is that your balance grows and the
they they act they're blessing you with
this low payment while your balance
keeps ballooning every single month so
what you need to do is get as much
income as you can live off as little as
you can and throw the difference at this
debt to where you're putting $1,000 a
month $2,000 a month to this debt $3,000
a month I hope to God you make six
figures what do you earn no no I I make
about 4,400 uh per month net what was
your
degreeing uh they in business degrees
and I I tried pursuing those careers but
they didn't suit me and I ended up
leaving those jobs I I taught I was a
teacher for about six years and now I'm
in a position where I'm I'm working with
adults teaching um people with uh visual
impairments to uh use computers um it's
a relatively new job um but it's uh
something that suits me and I'm I'm
doing well at it um but I I doe I need
to increase my income and so as my other
question is like are there any side
hustles that you recommend where I could
well we need to get your core income up
my kids that okay I don't think you're
can side host your way out of 200 Grand
making 50 we got to get your core income
up to 100 and then you do side hustles
on top of that that's so true yeah
that's that's exactly it do you have
kids yeah three kids um they're with me
5050 one week on one week off so it's
hoping to that's part of why I like this
job on that is because the schedule of
it you know lets me spend time with them
when they're with me listen here's
here's what I'm going to say to you if
you put if you put the math you gave us
in a calculator you're not pulling
paying these things off until
2124 which is not a real thing you know
and so you've got to I'm just going to
tell you what Sam and I did Sam's my
husband we said to ourselves cuz we were
in the same situation you were our when
we started out our court income was
30,000 combined that's laughable and so
you do to George's point you have to set
out on this journey and go and sit down
and plot out and say what does it look
like for me to double and then triple
and then maybe even quadruple my core
income what does that look like where do
I want to be 10 years from now and kind
of change the conversation where do I
want to be 10 years from now because the
fact of the matter is if I don't see
that plann through this debt doesn't get
paid off right and so then in the
meantime while you're carrying out that
plan you're still side hustling and
you're using all of your time to start
paying off this debt as much as you can
and you're not going to see the traction
that you're hoping to see right in that
first year but you still keep after it
and you have to play both sides of this
plan out in order to ultimately see
where you want to go cuz we can sit here
and say hey yeah pick up some Uber eats
or go do but that's not going to do what
raising your court income does so that's
your homework going away from this is
okay what does that look like for me I'm
putting down ideas on paper before you
get off the phone we want to make sure
you get connected with Ken Coleman's
information on Career assessments and
building a resume and just load them up
with king Coleman because that's that's
where this conversation has to go in
order for you to be bringing in the
money that you need to be to pay off
this debt and I don't say that to be
hopeless that's just real talk like the
budget tells your money what to do but
you have to feed the budget money so
getting on a budget is so so key but
you're going to see that budget and go
oh man I've got a long ways to go but
the good news is is you can take that
journey and even if it takes four or
five years you are going to see the
other side of this and you're going to
come out better for it I can tell you
that so here's what the math looks like
on this Charlie if you said hey I'm
going to pay this thing off in four
years so that's about 45k a year we have
to throw at this well that's 3750 a
month we have to throw at this now the
question becomes how do we create that
margin by spending less and making more
and that's a scary math problem but now
it's actually doable it's actual facts
in front of us real numbers that's good
George and so I just want to I I I'm not
here to beat you up or yell at you but
right now we can't just do what suits us
right now is not the time to chase down
our passions we got to go bust our butt
for the next four years to get out of
this mess otherwise you're going to look
up that loan's going to be 200,000 by
next year 220 by the next year 250 by
the year after that and then you're
going to really be hopeless cuz you
can't bankrupt on loans that's right no
doubling your income changes this entire
equation George George giving you those
numbers you you suddenly see it in bite
size chunks right what does it have to
take to get $3,750 extra dollar a month
but that might mean okay I got to rent
for a while I'm going to get a roommate
if I have to whatever you got to do four
years I mean you're a young guy how old
are you 36 you're 36 so imagine this by
the time you're 40 you're done with this
debt you're moved on to the new chapter
of Charlie's life you're building the
fully funded emergency fund you're
investing for the future from 40 to 62
this is a plan to still retire with some
dignity sure enough versus carrying this
these debts to the grave and leaving
your family broke I know that's right
and if I'm you I'm writing that number
$3,750 I'm writing it on my mirror with
a sharpie so that I can see it every
morning when I wake up I'm putting it on
the fridge I'm telling the kids I I'm
dreaming about that number every single
night because that's what my goal is and
that's what's going to drive all of this
and next to that number it needs to be
very clear in black and white why why do
I need this you got three kids you're
newly divorced you've got a whole new
life in front of you there's got to be a
really clear uh I'm not just paying off
this debt just to pay off this debt just
just check a box off the list you've got
to have a really Clear Connection as to
why this is necessary and that's what's
going to drive your your um desire to
get it done and we're going to hook you
up with every dollar as well that's our
budgeting tool we'll give you the
premium version what this is going to do
is help you actually see in the budget
if you have that 3,750 bucks in margin
every month and if you don't the budget
will show you where the gaps are where
the money leaks are and so you've got to
follow that to a tea and let that be
your guide for the next four years for
the next 40 years as you begin to build
wealth so I'm sorry what you went
through Charlie man it when you get
knocked down like that it can be so hard
to get up especially when you got a
mountain to climb on the other side with
student loans it's so true and the fact
is we tell people all the time the
average person gets out of debt in two
years or less but everybody's not
average right right in the center of
average is in the center and there's
people on the right and to the left of
that and that's okay if you fall to the
right of that equation my husband and I
fell to the right of that equation it
took us seven years George camel I would
not trade that seven years for anything
because when you walk through the fire
you come out a much better version of
yourself and that's what's going to
happen to Charlie this is the ramsy
show
hey guys Ramsey Solutions started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
netw Suite it works for us and it'll
help your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay netw Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
Net's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's nets.com
Ramsey 10 9 8 7 6 5 4
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I am
Jade warshaw this is George campel and
we are your hosts for today uh you can
give us a call the number is 8825 5225
and we are happy to discuss whatever it
is that's on your mind as it relates to
your life your money your career maybe
even your mental health we can try to
dive into that a little bit although Dr
John delone is not here so maybe save
those ones for you know what doesn't
help people's mental health what's that
taxes oo I know that's right it's Upon
Us Jade it is tax season they get a
whole season it's like there was
birthday month but tax is like no tax
season yeah I'm not for it matter of
fact when I think about taxes there's a
very memorable social media video that
pops into my mind you may have seen it
uh James can we play
it where's all your money going
dnie 6 9 10
11 let me fix my houses
but it's okay it's part of the game no
it's not not fun it's not fun to
what it's the worst part of the game of
is what
tax that's amazing go so for context
it's like I don't know an a 9-year-old
playing Monopoly and he's in tears
because he's paying taxes giving away
all of his money listen I feel that
realizing this is adulthood buddy it
feels even worse when it's not Monopoly
money well Dave Dave has always said if
the tax man showed up at your door and
you had to hand over $100 bills every
time you got a paycheck there would be a
Revolt in this country that tax man
would be getting whooped every time
Boston Tea Party all over again I'd be
dumping some Earl gry in that Harbor
well let's try to help people not feel
like the young man in that in that video
let's let them know kind of what to
prepare for in 2024 and what you we're
going to help you know what you need to
know about taxes uh coming up number one
when do you even need to file your taxes
guys the deadline is April 15th this
year the actual tax date most of us
think of April 15th as being the tax it
got switched up I think last year but
we're back on track we're back on track
so you you need to be sure that you're
filing everything all your federal tax
returns and payments by that date and
just know that you can start filing like
you don't have to wait till the last
minute go ahead and start now matter of
fact e beers out there that's right
listen that's me I try to get it done
ASAP I'm already sending the stuff over
over uh so start filing at the end of
January so that you're not putting it
off and uh get your paperwork ready I
know that we have a great checklist you
can use ramseys solutions.com taxes a
completely free uh checklist of all the
documents you need I print this out
every year Jade as I actually did it
this weekend my wife's like what are you
doing I'm like I'm getting all of our
documents ready for taxes George cuz you
know all the stuff just started coming
in it's the end of January so you've got
all the
W2s statements HSA contrib
it's all and so I like what I do I get
it all digital even if I take a picture
of it scan it in crop it put it in one
folder wow George on my computer so I'm
ready to go that's good I I'm just
pulling it from everywhere and I have a
bunch of papers and they're probably
like dog eared corners and I can't live
like that it's too stressful for me okay
this is good to note though if you uh
request an extension the deadline is
October 15th that's right but don't
don't request an extension just go on
and do it all right income tax brackets
guys did go up in 2023 uh for the 2024
tax season they also went up a few
hundred to account for inflation so if
it goes up it's to account for inflation
uh the more the taxpayer earns the more
their earnings are subject to higher
rates but don't get it twisted it's not
to say that your whole income is taxed
at that higher rate it's just the
portion of your income that put you to
the next tax bracket that gets
thank you for saying that I just
explained this on a YouTube video we
also have an explainer on that website
ramsy solutions.com taxes yes your
marginal tax rate versus your effective
tax rate not to get too nerdy but
they're different right even if you're
in the 22% tax bracket what you actually
ended up paying in taxes is probably
closer to 15% that's right your whole
income is not taxed at that that's
that's good St stepped so standard
deduction increased this year so it's
13,850 if you're single filer 27,700 for
married couples filing jointly right
that's good the other option would be to
itemize but ain't nobody got time for
that I feel like most people now it
makes more sense to do the standard
deduction as they've kept upping it you
just end up uh you know better off if
you're a normal everyday person I feel
that all right the IRS did bump up our
401K in IRA
contribution inves I love that the in
the limit did increase um and for Roth
contributions as well I think it went up
from 6,500 to 7,000 just on that base
limit they increase the income limits
cuz before if you made over a certain
amount that's right you know you were
capped you couldn't invest so they
increased that as well which is all good
we like that part love that all right
1099 K update George oh this is a juicy
one so people were freaking out about
this one J cuz they're like are they
going to start tracking my venos and
make me pay taxes and here's the deal if
you sell goods or services online you
may have heard about these these 1099
1099 K extra taxes in 2024 but those
policies have been officially delayed so
you're off the hook this year this year
oo all right so how can people save
money this tax season number one look
for tax deductions remember tax
deductions are things that help lower
your amount of taxable income right um
these are things like medical charitable
uh business things like that but tax
credits are actual dollar amounts that
are subtracted from your actual tax bill
which is nice they're deductible things
like child tax credit dependent Care
Credit education credit earned income
tax credit I I just like the word credit
when it means something's going back
into my account that's the only time I
way I remember is deductions are on the
front end and credits are sort of on the
back end yeah I like that so you know if
you make 200 Grand well the deductions
could help lower that to where the
government says no you really made 180
yeah and the credits are hey you owe
$10,000 on your tax bill but with these
credits you owe 2,000 that's right I so
it's kind of like your final bill goes
down with those credits it's like a
coupon yeah I love a coupon tax coupons
this is really important uh a lot of
people who are like I wanted to fund my
Roth IRA for the year or that health
savings account you can actually do that
up through April 15th yes so if you
missed it in 2023 you're like dang it
it's not too late but you got to do it
by April 15th yeah and to note if you're
investing in a Roth for the first time
fund the 2023 one first don't just go oh
it's 2024 I'm going to fund that one
because you can't go back in time so
fund the 2023 one first because it'll
still show up there as able to do
contributions and then as you get to it
because hopefully you can do more than
one fund the 2024 one and you'll get
double for your trouble this year there
we go and lastly uh if you're getting a
big refund every year stop celebrating
okay you're giving the government an
interest free loan all year when that
money could have been in your paycheck
being added to your every dollar budget
to help you accomplish your goals and
most people Jade they see this refund as
like fun money to go blow on the
vacation no don't do that change your
withholdings with your HR department or
whatever you need to do to try to get it
as close to as zero as possible that's
the game that is the game well if you
find this helpful or if you want more
information please go to Ramsey
solutions.com
taxes or if you want to read a little
bit more we've got a tax guide we've got
blog articles uh all sorts of things
that tax prep list that George and I
were uh so delicately and eloquently
talking about so delicate um but yeah
we've got everything there taxes should
not feel like a headache and if they
have in the past I promise you if you
use these resources we have it's going
to feel a lot better y are you doing tax
pro this year what are you what are you
in s my mother-in-law is our tax Pro
that is the best yeah well or she all up
in your business literally she's all up
in your business listen she's all up in
the Kool-Aid she knows the flavor and
it's she knows what's in the mix she
knows what's in the mix it is what it is
and I'm happy to have her that's nice
love you I just I just scheduled my tax
appointment I'm excited I'm looking
forward to it you know what I do this is
real talk my wife and I always schedule
a fun date post taxes I like that we go
to a nice lunch after okay and so that's
something that we look forward to so
that's a little I'm sure that's in
atomic habits right if like you got to
dangle a little carrot after you eat
your vegetable maybe it's a not a carrot
it's like a donut yeah dangle that's
true to get excited about taxes you know
the thing is like I feel like it's one
of those things that we've just kind of
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
we've told ourselves I hate tax season
tax season's the worst and then
therefore we make it the worst like we
don't prepare we don't do the things to
make it easier let's let this year be
different and set the the course for a
more enjoyable tax season let's go get
the the checklist go use Smart tax if
you want to do it on your own yeah like
set it set yourself up for Success it
doesn't have to be it's like the dentist
right get the shot of novacaine so that
it doesn't hurt get some laughing gas if
you have to there you go but get those
teeth cleaned all right we don't want
them those Chompers little chick mouth
chicklets all nasty mouth chicklets keep
them keep it tight that's what you're
here for George terms like terms like
mouth chicklets that's what people
listen to the Randy show for they're
listening to the Ramsey Show to go to
ramsy solutions.com taxes so they can
get their taxes done right this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw your host joined by George
Campell your other host give us a call
the number is 88255 225 and we will take
your calls and not only will we take
your calls during this hour and the two
to follow but after the show today
George and I are having a really uh it's
a new it's a new thing that we're doing
George we are doing a live Q&A uh
answering your questions about budgeting
and we will have the every dollar app
the best budgeting app in the world
pulled up uh so that we can use the app
to guide you through your questions so
you can kind of get an idea um of how
the app works for your situation it's
not a demo we're just answering your
questions and showing you how to do it
in the app if applicable and so this is
an exclusive live stream happening on
the Ramsey Show YouTube channel so make
sure you head to the YouTube channel now
as soon as you hear this and hit the
notify me button so that you don't miss
it 5:00 p.m. central Time today Tuesday
January 30th you can use the chat to ask
questions and you can also call into the
show as uh you normally can so this is
going to be cool we've never done an
after hours exclusive ramsy show
essentially after hours for one hour I
love it so we'll a lot of hours the show
today J it is I like it listen we're
here for the people we want to help you
guys out it means uh it's very important
for us to be some Monster energy drinks
for us I can't do that you'll see
another side of me but let's go to
Austin and Greensboro North Carolina
what's going on Austin hey how's it
going guys thank you for taking my call
you bet hey so um so my question was you
know we just we're new to the Financial
Peace University we just started it
we're uh I think we just finished video
number three or four great and uh well
wanting to get, saved up and so on and
so forth and get our get our get debt
free uhuh but the biggest problem is is
that the truck payment you know it's
it's Nigerian truck and I love it but
I'm willing to sell it I I'd rather get
rid of it enough become debt free but
the problem is is that I owe about right
on under 40,000 is 39800 something okay
and uh just because of the market the
way the market been going is that the
truck at the the value the truck has
dropped down to around
33 and so I'm wanting to sell it and
it's $880
payment yeah yeah it hurt how much do
you make a year uh uh last year we
made 65,000 I think myself okay um but I
started the new year off on a raise and
that's actually how I got the class was
I was talking to my boss about like
what's going on and and he's taking the
class he bought a for me which is
awesome of them but the biggest problem
is trying to get rid of this truck it is
drowning me like I obviously have to
have a vehicle to get back and forth to
work in well how's your credit three
kids how's your
credit is not very good well if you were
to if you were to go to a credit union
around town to see if you could maybe
get this 7,000 to bridge that Gap do you
think you could do
that uh possibly but then I feel like
the because we were thinking about that
then the problem would be if we do that
then we have to find a down payment for
something else cuz uh whatever we get
has to be we have three children me and
my wife do so we I can't just go get an
old
moped yeah what's your other
car my my wife's car is a Ford Explorer
my car is a Chevrolet Silverado B does
she work outside the
home she doesn't know but she uses the
car to take the children to school so
what if she dropped you at work
took the kids to school picked you up
listen carpol with a friend car pool it
there's so there's so many options I my
husband and I were a onecar family for
10 years and my sister who they both
worked on opposite ends of town with two
boys were a onecar family for 5 years
it's a pain in the butt and it's
inconvenient and you have to do a lot of
planning and scheduling but you want to
know what you don't have an $880 car
payment exactly yeah so there's only two
ways to get out of this either you come
up with the difference that 7 Grand plus
what you need to get another beater car
or you get that personal loan from the
credit union to cover the difference
plus what you need for the other
car yeah but there's no life hacks here
this is one of the riskiest Parts about
going into debt for vehicles and let me
tell you Austin you're not the first one
to call the show this week being
underwater on a car it's happening All
Over America cuz people got star eyed
when they got that dream truck and now
it's a
nightmare preach and dude you make 60
Grand you drive a $40,000 truck I don't
drive a $40,000 car and I'm a
millionaire yeah like what were you
thinking at the time of purchase
here so uh at the time um I the car I
was driving back and forth working blew
up on me so we had to go to the
dealership and get something I watch
what your words there you had to go to
the
dealership we chose to go because we had
to get a vehicle you thank you that's
all I ask for is well honesty I'm
playing with you but you see how all of
these decisions happen because well we
had to and the car blew up and it's all
stressful and we had to go $440,000 into
debt that's the American way right there
and the reason that people don't have
let me let me take it one back further
George the reason that people's cars
blow up and they think oh instead of
paying the bill to get it fixed for $700
I don't have $700 so I'll just go get a
brand new car is they've had payments
forever and they had so many payments
that they didn't have any money saved
and because because they didn't have any
money saved they had to go back into
payments it's a wheel and you've got to
break that cycle and and get out of the
wheel because if you get rid of this
$880 payment and either you carpool or
you find a way to you know get a couple
thousand dollar and get a beater you are
effectively breaking that cycle and
instead of $880 going to CarMax or ford
financing it's going to BU it's a it's
going to pay off your debt but then it's
going to go to build you a nice cushy
emergency fund and the next time your
car blows up because it will everybody
has car issues you're going to just go
down to Christian Brothers or wherever
you get your car fixed and you're just
going to hand them the cash for $770 or
for
$1,250 when something happens and you're
not going to say well my only choice
here is to get a brand new car on
payments you're going to be prepared for
it so let's break that
cycle absolutely yeah I agree with we
got to get the income up and if that
means the wife is going out to work when
you get home from work so you can watch
the kids or you're getting that second
job we need to come up with this money
fast and that mean selling stuff do you
have any other
debt uh yes we do uh in including the
truck total is like 55,000 so you got
another 15 and
what uh some of his credit cards some of
this uh medical bills things like that
okay so let's snowball these smallest to
largest once we get rid of this car loan
the rest are going to go smallest to
largest balance ignore the interest
rates get that income up as high as
possible no eating out no luxuries it's
time to batten down the hatches and get
of this debt and you can do this this
can all be done probably in the next for
you I'm thinking 6 months you got a very
different financial situation I think
there's two options you and your wife
have to choose before between and it's
either two options or both it can either
be listen we're car pooling and it's
going to be a pain in the butt or it's
she's got to pick up extra work so that
you guys can pay this thing off super
duper fast or at least save up pay make
the payment while saving up to bridge
the gap between the seventh out like
you've got some some options but one of
them is going to either of them is going
to require deep sacrifice and there's no
getting around that part of it there's
no easy button really to hit in this
equation so I think that that's that's
the hard part that they're going to have
to choose between George well it just
makes me think Jade you know debt always
requires sacrifice but it's a much more
painful sacrifice than the other kind
which is we're going to sacrifice and
save up and pay cash for this car with
delay gratification we're going to only
buy the car that we can afford which is
going to limit what kind of car purchase
yeah that's a different kind of
sacrifice but it's much more painful on
the other side when you're trying to
clean up a mess and interest is is
hurting your ability to knock this debt
down and you got three kids and we have
the mortgage and we got the student
loans and it all just starts to weigh on
you the pain of staying the same has to
become greater than the pain of changing
and that's really what it's getting to
you've got to feel so stressed and sick
and tired and frustrated in your
day-to-day life that suddenly that
becomes so painful that that the pain of
change it's like listen I'll take that
like I remember getting to the point of
being like I want a new set of problems
like I know what it feels like to not be
able to pay bills on time and to be
arguing with my spouse and to just be in
this state of constant Financial
disarray that I was ready to take on new
problems of okay how do we schedule our
our life how like how do we balance only
having one car how do we figure out
conversations around the budget how do
we figure out you know trade your old
set of problems in for a new set of
learnings and that are you know a a
better set of problems which is really
just you being uncomfortable while
you're getting out of debt and that car
Jade is like you you put 40 Grand on the
loan you ended up paying 50 after
interest now it's worth 20 after you
done paying for it that hurts my brain
yeah oh it's painful listen that car
note that's what's keeping the middle
class middle class those who get rid of
their car note get something called
money and are able to build something
called wealth this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host today Jade
warshaw joined by your other host today
George camel and we are taking your
calls something that is so fun and
enjoyable to do we're happy that you
trust us with that if you want to call
in you can call call in at 8825 5225 and
we will do our best to help guide you to
the next right step that's all we can do
Jade that's all we can do try our best
and next step we can't solve The World's
problems but we can at least help you in
three minutes that we have together I
know that's right so let's go to the
phone lines where we have Dustin in
Albuquerque New Mexico what's going on
Dustin uh hi how's it going good um well
I uh this past year um 2023 was my first
full year of owning a house and I had
always heard uh people who own houses
don't really get a tax return back so I
went to do my taxes and um sure enough
he said I was going to get like a $100
back and their fee is like uh just over
300 so he he recommended I take um some
money out of my 401k from 2023 and put
it in an IRA and and he said if I put
like
$4,000 um I would probably get like a at
least a$7 or $800 return on my taxes
rather than $100 return this guy's fire
I wanted
to
instantly keep talking talk what I
understand is you're going to get a $100
refund right
now yeah like aund and something and
their fee to work with the tax Pro is
300 bucks and you don't have the 200
bucks to cover it is that the problem
well I was going to I was going to put
it on my credit card and he said well if
you want you could do this and it would
cover our fee and you would get um you
know some money back he suggested a 401k
loan is he saying to withdraw the money
from the 401K or is he saying do it
transfer from an old 401k do a direct
rollover what exactly he was he saying
to
do um if I understood right he wanted me
to roll over like $4,000 from my 401k
from an old employer from my earnings
from 2023 no uh I'm still working with
this employer well
you okay you're not going to be able to
do a rollover unless you leave that
employer oh okay so what he's saying to
do it sounds like he's saying to
withdraw money from the 401K he wants
him to withdraw it to pay to
pay cause you to pay 3% penalties and
taxes in order to do
that oh okay I didn't know that listen
if yeah I I don't trust this tax guy
first of all he's missing a few brain
cells here's the thing telling you to do
this so that you can cover the three
$200 $300 fee you ow George we can't we
we're expending way too many mental
calories trying to understand that this
tax guy is whack here's the thing here's
at the core of this you're getting $100
back that's great that means you didn't
overpay taxes and comma
you have to pay them for their services
so I think right now you've just got to
break your mind for a moment because
what's happening is is normal like I
don't pay that much in taxes and I have
to pay my tax guy like that that right
there is actually normal what's what or
what should happen is what I should say
what's normal is people get back $88,000
and they don't even feel that they paid
their tax professional because they're
getting out back these exorbitant
amounts and they're thinking that they
won the lottery that their tax guy did
something wonderful for them when really
all they did was just loan the
government money all year long and
didn't even collect any interest on it
and so I kind of want to reframe your
brain there and just go listen you're
it's great you didn't get a tax refund
back that just means you didn't overpay
the government you had access to all of
your money all year long which is a good
thing and now you got to pay these guys
for their services no harm no foul like
that's that's the way it should
be so when do you have to make this
well he we were doing my Texas this past
weekend and he just put it on hold um
you know until I I looked into he told
me to look into the IRA and to see if I
could take money out of my 401k but then
I heard about you guys um you know I've
never really listened to the show but I
heard about you guys so I thought I'd
call out I'm so glad you did Dustin
truly so here's the deal I'm going to go
how much can I work what can I sell in
order to make $300 to to pay this guy's
tax fee but then I'm done with them yeah
we're not taking out 401K loans to pay
our tax guy for our income tax
return okay and um I I don't know if I
can ask to um I I've always wondered
about like a Roth IRA what a like should
I just stick with my 401ks or should I
consider moving to like a do you have
any
debt um just the house uh just your
mortgage pay house no credit card debt
no car
payment well I have a a little bit of
credit card de like $600 but like I
travel I travel for work so I use my
credit card like to eat and I travel for
work I use my debit card yeah and that
way I can't go into debt and if they if
they're causing you to go into debt they
need to provide you a company card for
that but do not put company expenses on
a credit card because if something
happens you're you're on the hook if
they fire you or whatever and they're
like you know we don't even know what
you're talking about that's not an
expense anymore you're on the hook for
that bill
dude well to to be honest I do the
credit card because I can't really
afford to put anything on my debit card
like I I literally then they need to
provide you some petty cash or some
funds in order to do those things but
you should not be going into debt on a
monthly basis to fund purchases for your
job like Hardline
but even if like they pay me back the
very next week because you're in debt
you're in debt your name is on the line
until they decide to pay you back
because what happens if you do something
and you're like listen I thought that
was an expense you're paying 25%
interest on this balance in the meantime
yeah so Dustin the real question is why
don't you have any margin even though
you don't have much debt right if $300
is an issue yeah I'm confused like how
much do you
make well after my taxes and and my
insurance get like $1,500 every two
weeks okay so three grand a month are
you doing any investing right now into
that
41k well yeah what what whatever um I
mean I don't know exactly how much it is
but it's just whatever my job put
forward well it's about to be 0% because
right now you need $1,000 in a starter
emergency fund because you're going to
keep going back into credit card debt if
we don't solve
this so Paul's investing down to zero
right now go get some side jobs start
selling stuff pay the 300 bucks to your
tax guy save up 1,000 bucks in the
emergency fund and then let's get rid of
this credit card debt and then we can
get back to investing hey how much is
your
mortgage so every month my mortgage
actually went up this year because they
underestimated my taxes for last year so
it went up um to just under $2,000
that's the problem gracious there's your
problem bud your problem 2third of your
money is going into this home yeah
the rule of thumb here is we don't want
your mortgage to be any more than 25% of
your take-home pay after taxes and you
are well above that and that's why
you're feeling the heat that's why you
don't have any money saved that's why
it's hard to pay this $300 tax bill and
your brain even considered the idea of
getting a 401k loan for it we've got to
we've got to get this ship writed stay
tuned keep following us and we'll teach
you how to do that this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for listening to the Ramsey Show
I'm Jade warshaw this is George camel
we're with you for the next couple hours
talking about your life and your money
and I have to say George you know one of
the things I love most about being here
at Ramsey Solutions is our Live Events
like I love off the chains they're off
the hook man I love when we all get
together it's like a rally and we have a
really great one coming up this year May
10th and 11th it's our Total Money
Makeover weekend which is a two-day
event listen it's all the personalities
there myself George Ken John deloney
Rachel Cruz of course the goat himself
Dave Ramsey and we're coming at you with
all new material like that's the part
that I'm really excited about is it's
just a completely new
fresh situation if you will and no
matter where you are on the baby steps
if you're new to the plan you've been
hanging out with us for 20 years this is
going to be a pep rally and crash course
when everything we teach about money and
again it's all new content and we're
also going to make it interactive with
live q&as we've got a live smart money
happy hour recording with Rachel Cruz
and I that'll be a blast and uh our
events are actually fun so you don't
have to like drag people to these events
when they get there they're like oh goes
hard in the paint yeah we'll make sure
it's a good mix of information and
entertainment and light-heartedness this
is not a seminar that's right oh yeah
def never that never that but early bird
ticket starts at $99 but that's only
going to be for a limited time so if you
want to get the tickets at the $99 price
you need to get online today at ramseys
solutions.com events because let me tell
you something these tickets they go they
gone like they go fast it's here at the
Ramsey Event Center just up the hill
from the Ramsey studio and so it's a
Nashville is a great destination make
plans get it in the budget to be here uh
bring a spouse that's a great I mean I
feel like people leav in their marriages
are better listen that's so true George
and you made the point no matter what
baby step you're on this truly is an
event for you if you're if you're new to
the baby steps or you've been in the
baby steps this is the perfect event for
you and you know George it's funny cuz
you know we've been we we all teach from
a series of seven baby steps and that's
kind of just the Crux of everything we
do and everything we talk about and uh I
kind of want to take a moment and talk
about that because so many people are
new to list and they're like I think I
get it and they call in the show and
they've got some questions and you know
there's just some basic teaching that I
feel like we can always learn no matter
where we are in the steps and so like we
had a call last yeah from Dustin from
Dustin and it's like he was new and the
more we talked to him the more we
started uncovering more and more things
about his situation that's like okay
he's he we got to get him lined up on
the baby steps matter of fact Dustin
this event might be for you if you can
afford to to to get there get that $99
ticket rate but George let's take a
moment and just for the person who's
listening to the Ramsey show for the
very first time let's kind of unpack
some of those basic foundational things
around the baby steps because obviously
the the very F first baby step is baby
step one get $1,000 saved but you kind
of have to understand some of the Nuance
around why that is and what else goes
along with that so that it makes sense
in your mind and you're not just doing
what a radio personality or a podcast or
a YouTuber told you to do right yeah
this is big and so there's really kind
of a prerequisite of baby Step Zero
which is getting current on all of your
bills and actually paying attention to
your money for the very first time and a
lot of people Jade I mean they don't
know how much debt they're in they don't
really know what's happening and so you
might need to pull your credit report
just to see what the heck is going on in
your financial world and get some hard
numbers and look at your actual pay
stubs and see where's my money going how
much is coming in and then make sure
you're current on all of your bills if
you're behind we have to get current
that's right I'd call that getting
organized like the first thing that
you're doing just just get organized
like George said let's log in let's look
at the credit report let's log in and
see what really is our what really do we
owe right what's our payment because so
many times I'm like listen what do you
owe and they're like well I'm not really
sure how can you solve the problem if
you don't really know what the problem
is and one of the things I'd add to that
and you can add to your list too is baby
step zero a big part of that is just
saying you know what I've got a problem
probably your problem is debt I'm just
going to stop Bor money here for a
minute like I'm going to stop
contributing to the problem while I
figure out how to solve it stop the
bleeding you got to stop you can't solve
a problem while simultaneously creating
it so just if you don't do anything else
today just make a decision I'm not going
to borrow money anymore cuz right now
it's just caused me to get into this
situation of disarray so I'm going to
cut it off I'm not borrowing any money
and that's kind of your baby step zero
that's me prepping right to get ready to
do this thing so now this is like the
Subterranean level so if I'm playing The
Devil's Advocate I'm that person I'm
going well Jade I've been living off of
my credit card because I don't have
money what how am I going to do this
without going further into debt I think
the next step that brings us to our next
step which is kind of the Subterranean
is the budget because if you can create
a budget you can see where all of your
money is going and most of our disarray
or most of our you know frustration
around money centers from we don't know
where it's all going we get this
paycheck we go to work every single day
we get a paycheck and somehow we still
feel like we're leaving paycheck
paycheck we still feel like we can't
make ends meet and it's usually because
we're just spending our money
haphazardly and I always say your money
is expensive like you the the paycheck
that you get think about everything that
it costs you right it's costing you time
away from your family less sleep time
away from the things that you want to be
doing possibly let's treat it with care
because it's very expensive and it costs
us a lot so treating your money with
care means getting on a budget you don't
just think about if you went George
think about if you went to the mall this
week and you bought that brand new Louis
Vuitton bag you know me $3,000 bag are
you going to just go into your home and
just take it and just toss it across the
room and let it hit the corner of the
closet and just be there next to Old
tennis shoes and no you're not you're
going to like dust it off and put it on
a nice shelf you know exactly where it
belongs it's the same thing with your
money if you get a $3,000 check you
better treat that thing with care don't
just toss it around and hope that it
ends up in the right place organize it
and put some care into it and that's
what you do with a budget so and you
don't have to be like a giant Excel nerd
luckily we created a budgeting app long
ago that is amazing called every dollar
so all you do is go to your app store go
to everydollar.com and just list your
income digitally type in your income
type in a few of your expenses we guide
you through this you don't have to be a
financial Prodigy to create a budget
that's right you just have to be willing
to pay attention yeah I love every
dollar cuz I know for me I'm like uh I
hate doing math it just found it feels
like math George that's why you wrote a
book called money's not a math problem
that's right and every that's right and
every dollar does that math for you it
does all the equations everything like
that it truly you can build a
budget when Excel when you hit the cell
the wrong way and it's like formula's
messed up I'm like I I just quit out of
excel I can't handle it I don't even
know about that because I don't even log
into XL it ruins my day there we go
that's a good step though we got to get
current on the bills stop borrowing
money get on a plan that's called a
budget and then what well let's start
looking at some of the symptoms that
you're experiencing because if you're
like Destin and you call in you think
the problem is I owe the tax guy
$300 but that's just a symptom of a
bigger problem so I kind of wrote this
little list here George that are
symptoms that you might need a financial
plan and that you might need to get on
the Ramy plan um if you're kind of
circling you know you kind of been
hanging out around the cooler the water
cooler but you haven't dove into our
plan yet so number one if you're feeling
uh confusion about your finances if
somebody talks about your money and the
first emotion you feel it's kind of like
fear frustration anxiety confusion
that's a sign it's like when I'm in a
conversation about sports I start to get
a little sweat on the brow like they're
going to find me out in no time J that's
right that's a symptom of a bigger
problem if small bills $150 $200 if
those are stressing you out that's a
symptom okay uh if your mortgage payment
or your rent payment is a strain that's
a symptom of a bigger problem because
that should be a blessing not a burden
if you're consider in extreme
options to deal with what should be
minor problems like this guy he's
considering a 401k loan to pay for a
$300 tax bill if you're going to rob
yourself or turn to more debt to solve
the problem you're in a drastic
situation you need to pause that's good
George you're using debt to pay off debt
o and then finally and we talked about
this if you're not on a budget these are
all symptoms of much much bigger
problems and so those are kind of that's
kind of like the sub terranean level
before you start the baby steps like
recognizing those symptoms and saying
hey I need to be on a plan okay I'm
going to do what George said I'm going
to get organized I'm going to find out
what I owe and I'm going to stop
borrowing money and then I'm going to
get on a budget those are the things
that final step you got to figure out
how to spend less and make more and
that's called margin in your budget now
we can start saving up that ,000
emergency fund and getting rid of our
debt so uh join us if you want a crash
course on money ramsy solutions.com
events Total Money Makeover weekend go
check out dollar it's a free app and uh
all of that's just going to help you wi
in 2024 that's what we're here for yeah
and when you come to that realization
it's worth doing that Subterranean work
because then when you actually start
working the baby steps you know why
you're doing it and you understand why
and how it's the solution to your
problem this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything cost too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blind .c is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
this is the ramsy show taking calls
about your life your money I'm Jade
warshaw this is George camell let's go
directly to the phone lines where we've
got Lindsay in Detroit Michigan what's
going on
Lindsay hi um my husband and I just had
our second baby last fall and now this
year we're going to be looking at paying
about $16,000 in daycare um yeah we were
already pretty much feeling like we were
paycheck to paycheck and it just kind of
seems like everything's hitting at once
now I just I don't know where to start
in regards to like budgeting you know we
also have other debt that we're trying
to pay off but at the same time our
savings account is dwindling every month
and I just am not sure how to tackle
everything yeah um so are you guys using
a budget or not yet we're not we kind of
just started going into you know
printing off our make statements and
labeling everything and going from there
um but I know if we really want to save
we're going to actually have to itemize
every single thing out it's going to
help like being on a detailed I always
say a good budget is detailed realistic
and flexible and so of course I'm going
to recommend every dollar for you to
budget with because it's easy to do all
three of those things and when you're
heading into a new stage of life where
not only is day-to-day life changing but
like the way you're spending your money
is drastically changing that right there
can give you a big sense of control and
a big sense of Peace over what's going
on even if you don't actually have the
money to do all the things that you want
to do at least being able to see it on
paper or see you know digital paper
being able to see it there all laid out
and have a very clear uh number of what
you need in order to make it work
financially that can give you a lot of
Peace so just hearing your situation I
think getting off of here and making
sure that we connect you with every
dollar is the first thing um second
thing is let's look at your income and
let's see if we can determine what it is
that you need here on this call yeah
what are you guys bringing home every
month um I make about 60,000 and my
husband makes
45,000 okay so 105 total and then what's
your take-home pay every month once it
hits your bank um I would say about
3,000 for me in the checking account and
I put 600 into the savings every month
and then his varies a little bit but
it's probably around 2,000 a month month
okay so about 5,000 a month and then
you're taking out some for savings and
some other things are you guys
contributing to retirement at all we
both are his is minimal I think about
150 a month I am doing 12% right now so
I'm at like 650 a month okay well we
just found a way to free up $800 in your
budget every month so congratulations
and you'll get back to investing I
promise you you both will be at 15%
instead of struggling to get to 15% from
both incomes and so what we need to do
in the meantime is focus on one thing
cuz you're telling me I'm trying to put
some in savings I'm trying to invest I'm
trying to pay off debt we got to cover
the daycare you're doing a lot at once
and it's going to feel like you're never
going to make progress so we would
encourage you to walk this through the
baby steps which is one thing at a time
Focus intensity let's get $1,000 in
savings now we don't touch that unless
there's a true emergency now we're going
to focus on just debt payoff and not
invest for a little while until we get
to debt freedom then we get the fully
funded emergency fund now we're
investing again so that's going to
really help you guys out if you if you
pause savings how much do you have in
savings right
now um like maybe 4,000 okay good and
how much debt do you
have uh we pay about 700 a month in
student loans we have 10,000 on a helac
we have about 5,000 in credit cards uh
and then our mortgage payment a month is
about
783 so the student loan can you tell me
how much the big balance
is uh the big balance is probably 40 to
45,000 and you're paying
700 yeah is that the minimum or that's
just what you choose to
pay um so we actually had to refinance
that with a bank a few years ago because
we were paying 12% like privately so
this is just our payment a month and I
think in I think that maybe balloons in
about eight years so it's a private
loan yeah okay um okay so to George's
Point doing one thing at a time so
you've already got the $1,000 saved
which is baby step one you've got 3,000
above that saved so in walking through
the baby steps and I'm just going to
tell you what it is for right now and
then we can go back and hit any
objections and clarify it so based on
the baby steps you keep the ,000 aside
and then we take that $3,000 that's left
and we throw it at our smallest debt now
in this case it could be the $5,000
credit card or if you tell me that this
this student student loan is broken up
into smaller chunks it could be the
student loan is it just one big loan for
45,000 or is it a couple of loans
squished together um there's a big one
for 45 and then there's maybe three or
four that are around $1,000 each okay so
what I'm doing is I'm going to do the
three or four or the three that are
$1,000 each and I'm going to knock those
out really tomorrow and I'm going to
have $3,000 less of student loans and it
might seem minimal on paper but I can
tell you and I think you know this it's
just nice for that list to get shorter
like it's just nice to say I had four
student loans and now I only have one
right so that's going to feel great and
so now all we're doing here is we're
just listing the debts smallest to
largest by balance and we're paying them
off one at a time and what you're going
to find is when you pay off those three
little ankle biters or you know four
little ankle biters it's going to give
you so much like oh yes like it's gone
like oh I can do it and you're going to
realize like listen I can keep going and
so that's how that works and then once
you quickly as quickly as possible get
this debt cleaned up then we're going to
stack up that savings to six months 3 to
six months of expenses basic expenses
and then you're going to feel like nice
and secure and like okay I've
accomplished something then we're going
to rev back up that retirement and now
we're going to start back again
contributing to retirement and you're
going to do 15% of your gross monthly
income every single month more than
you've ever put away before and you're
going to make up the difference from the
time you lost cuz it's probably going to
take you oh let's see 45 55 60 it's
probably going to take you maybe
depending on how crazy you guys get
maybe it's going to take you two two and
a half years to pay off this debt and
get out of this two and a half years is
nothing it's a drop in the bucket to be
free at the end of it
yes so that's it in a nutshell now tell
me your
objections well the one qu or I guess my
biggest fear about the savings account
is although I'm putting you know 600 a
month it also seems like there's that
one one or two weeks during the month
where it seems like everything's coming
out and I end up almost transferring all
of that back into the checking account
every month and that's because you don't
have the budget what happens what you're
describing is something so common I have
experienced it maybe George you've
experienced it is you get excited and
you're like I'm adulting I'm going to
put some money aside for savings but
because you didn't do a detailed budget
you truly didn't have the $600 to put
aside and as the month starts to flesh
out you realize oh crap I actually
needed that money then you go pull it
back out of savings and it just deflates
your whole feeling of trying to adult so
if you just start with the budget then
you'll actually see listen do I even
have money to put aside for Savings in
your case it's possibly in in your case
you probably do but because you're not
on a budget and being very clear about
every dollar that you're spending it's
getting spent in another category but in
this case you don't need to put aside
another dollar for savings right now all
of your dollars need to be going towards
paying off these debts you got $4,000
saved like I said whether or not you're
going to go off this call and dwindle
that down to $11,000 that's between you
and God and your husband but at the very
least from this point on put all of that
extra cash towards debt don't keep
putting it towards savings because
you're losing valuable time that you
could be using paying off this debt okay
and that daycare will become a line item
in the budget and so that's what I love
about when you start that every dollar
budget you're going to say all right we
need 13 33 a month to cover daycare for
this month correct yep okay well we just
showed you how to free up 800 cuz we're
pausing investing right now we showed
you how to free up 600 CU you just are
going to pause all that saving and so
anything beyond your basic expenses food
utility shelter Transportation daycare
insurance premiums everything else needs
to go toward your debt yeah okay and
listen let me let me encourage you don't
don't feel like you have to do it all
because that's what gets you um
scattered and your money goes away
quickly it's almost like if you have
this big jug of water right and that's
your income and you're trying to put a
little bit of water in five different
jugs which is debt and savings and
retirement and you're just pouring a
little bit and then you have to go fill
up the jug and you pour a little bit
more what would it look like if you just
took that whole jug and you poured it
all in the in the other jug of debt
you'd fill it up so quickly and then you
go fill it up again and then when it's
time you can pour the whole jug into
savings and then you fill it up again
you can go so much quicker if you just
focus on one task at a time and that's
really how you move quickly to get this
done okay this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
you're listening to the ramsy show and
thank you for listening to the Ramsey
Show by the way if you enjoy this
podcast this YouTube channel uh the
radio show we would love it if you did
us the free favor of like liking it
subscribing it and of course sharing it
whether you share it on your socials you
send it in a text to a family member or
a friend or a cooworker whatever that
looks like for you we sure would
appreciate that because it benefits all
of us right it helps us in the
algorithms and of course you sharing the
message that hopefully we're sharing
which is a message of Hope and freedom
in your finances so we would sure
appreciate that and George our question
of the day today is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
almost nothing can ruin day faster than
a plumbing emergency show you right for
over 50 years Mr Rutter Plumbing has
been helping homeowners with upfront
pricing and the most stress-free
Plumbing experience possible so go to
neighbor.com Ramsey to find a locally
owned Mr Rutter Plumbing today's
question comes from Andrew in Texas he
says I'm a 27-year-old Army vet in
graduate school and I receive
compensation due to disabilities that
happened in the service my parents are
divorced and both have provided for me
and my brother in the past my Dad
recently asked me to help pay $1,800 for
watch repairs wanting to both please my
dad and out of fear of emotional
backlash I did so but I complained to my
mom about it because I needed to vent
mom texted Dad about my complaint and he
guilt tripped me by saying how many cars
have I provided for you and said he's
quote tired of the one-way Street of
giving do I owe my dad anything if not
how do I go about saying no to financial
assistance
requests oh
boy I wish I wish Papa was on the line
right
now there's a great quote about this I
can't think of it Jade it's like unex
uncommunicated expectations equals
future resentment or something like that
listen that's a great quote let's go
with that I just feel like this Dad in
this giving well I gave you all these
cards when you were younger I wish my
dad told me hey son I'm going to give
you these cars but one day you're going
to owe me some money and when I ask for
any money you just have to give it to me
that's part of the deal and I'd say then
I don't want these cars Dad this is a
very awkward
situation uh from Dad I don't think it's
fair to the son you don't owe anything
to your dad no if he chose to buy you
cars over the course of your you know
from the time you were 16 until 2 de he
made as a grown adult yeah and by the
way just as a parent the one-way Street
of
giving when we have kids we are called
to we're their Steward like we we get to
be in their lives and Steward them and
teach them how to be adults and raise
them up to go into the world it's not
about us getting something back at the
end of it in return if you go into it
like that listen you're setting yourself
up for some dysfunction which is what's
taking place right here can I just offer
a hot take I don't think parents should
ever ask their kids for money I don't
either is that re is that like very
controversial listen the the the no it's
not George the only time I'm thinking
listen I'm trying to think of every
possible situation my parents have never
asked me for money no I can I can trying
to think back I don't think it's ever
happened if I was in a situation where
I'm just this was not my situation but
if I grew up maybe in a single where
there was a single dad or a single mom
raising if I was 16 if we were maybe in
a part of the country where it's just
been really tough there's not a lot of
jobs or maybe we're trying to break a
cycle like we're in the of trying to
break a cycle I could see it's like hey
support this family if you wanted to
help support the family and help break
everybody out I'm not mad at um the idea
of It kind of being a family effort in
certain situations but give me
$1,800
to fix my watch or it's more like listen
I'm 16 I got a job at McDonald's I'm
trying to help my single mom make rent
and Junior decides to give some of that
money listen I'm not mad at that
but $1,800 to fix my watch so I'm trying
to think if I'm Andrew I got to approach
my dad I'd probably say something like
listen Dad I'm so grateful for
everything you did for my brother and I
to raise us to give us a great home to
provide for us in this way and for all
the past support but here's the deal I'm
limited now I'm trying to approach my
own financial goals and prioritize my
financial well-being and as much as I
want to give I can't do it financially
and I have to set this boundary and
prioritize my needs right now and and
zero apologies given and you don't need
to say I'm so sorry I'm a terrible son
don't let him guiltrip you if the the
relationship isn't worth that and truly
there's not much of a relationship if
it's based on this financial transaction
if this is the make or break for him
talking to you and being involved in
your life I'm sorry but you had a dad
and now he's become someone different
yeah and clearly this has happened
before because he already has the the
quote fear of emotion backlash like this
is he already kind of knows what this is
going to look like so you can offer him
other ways of support of hey Dad I'd
love to sit down with you and look at
your budget if he's willing to do that
and you want to sit with him and and
walk him through some numbers and show
him how to afford things and maybe gift
him a book that'll help him that's great
but you're not going to sit here cuz you
know what happens he gives him 1,800
bucks he's going to be getting hit up
next week no yeah yeah that's right that
is so so true yeah I think that's why I
never give to the alumni found Jade all
of a sudden they're hitting you up they
marked me on the list going this guy's
got money that's so so true that's
hilarious George yeah this this
situation this just makes me mad man I'm
going to cross it out not okay parents
don't do this to your kids yeah uh yeah
Andrew has nothing to feel bad about all
right let's go to the phone lines we've
got Thad I'm guessing short for Thaddius
in Los Angeles California was I right
about that Thad that's correct yeah love
it what's going on yeah thanks for
having me um so I'm a 28-year-old uh
overemployed software engineer I'm
single um I'm very happy with my income
but there's two main things I'm want to
address today the first thing is um I'm
happy with the amount of money I'm
saving every month but um the amount of
money I'm spending is concerning and it
gives me like a little bit of anxiety to
think about it even though it's
sustainable it's like uh
I'm worried if I just want to know if
that's valid anxiety or you know if yeah
you know if you make more money it's
okay to spend more money how
do right now I make 230,000 great how
much are you
saving right now it ranges between five
and 6,000 a month okay and that's after
everything after discretionary and needs
and on is that in investment account
retirement
accounts it's mixed I have um
I most of my money in in a brokerage and
I have some money for 1K you're
investing anywhere from 25 to 30% it
sounds
like at least okay do you have any
debt I have a car loan yes how much is
left on the car loan uh
40,000 how much do you have in
cash uh 10,000 in the bank and you have
money in the brokerage account you could
pay off the car
today yeah I have 60,000 The Brokerage
10,000 Bank 10,000 for 1K why haven't
you paid off the car why you hanging on
to the
loan
um good question I mean is that part of
the anxiety of spending is you your body
is kind of keeping the score going I owe
people money this car is going down in
value while I still have this $40,000
loan it's definitely possible and and
the monthly payments like you know it's
it's it's fine but it's yeah it's like
it it sucks would your life be better
without that
payment probably but also it's it's nice
to have $40,000 but it's not really
yours it's not really yours you have to
you have to do the full math you have to
do the full math minus what you owe
that's your net worth that's a much
better scoreboard than a credit score or
how much you have in a bank account
right right what other debt do you
have that's my only debt yeah okay and
so you said you're investing 25 to 30%
how much are you spending as a
percentage on are you spending five or
six grand a
month yeah so I think I spend on
everything about 60% and I save 40% so
yeah 640 right now okay are you doing
any
giving uh no okay I think that could be
part of it and I'll tell you why I think
there's only three things you can do
with money give save and spend and
you've got a flat tire right now you're
great at saving you're great at spending
I think giving could unlock something
for you and I do think we got to reain
in the spending and go why am I doing
this is it emotional retail therapy do I
need some friends
accountability re for that that's good
it's not lifestyle creep if you're doing
all the things you should be doing with
money uh you're on a budget you're
saving for retirement you are paying off
your debt you're practicing generosity
and you carry the proper insurances if
you're doing those five pillars it's not
lifestyle creep it's just living your
life like it's golden this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
la
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create and build actual
amazing relationships I'm your host Jade
warshot this is George camel and we're
taking your calls for the next hour
about your life and your money so give
us a call the number is
88255 25 and we'll do our best to help
you so George without further Ado let's
go straight to the phone lines and talk
to Sarah who's in Greenville South
Carolina hey Sarah what's going
on hi um I'm trying to determine if we
are going to have to go on uh Wick which
is the children's um government help
uhhuh um I've cut everything I can
possibly cut from our budget um but our
grocery bill even though I by only what
we need um is just with inflation um
we're just having to dip into our
savings and it's getting a little low
okay um tell me more what's in your
savings what's your oh go ahead I was
just calling to see if there's any other
suggestions probably let's let's dig
deeper so you said you're digging into
your savings so how much do you have in
your
savings um at this point we're down to
5,000 Okay so we've got 5,000 saved do
you have debt I'm guessing
yes um we have our house and one car
okay what do you owe on the one
car
um 11,000 okay 11,000 on that car and is
it your only car or do you have two
vehicles we have two the other ones paid
off okay great what's your annual
income uh 36 before for
taxes okay oh well there's our problem
annual income 36 there's two of you
who's working and who's
not uh my husband works full-time um I
stay home with our two sons okay how old
are the two
sons two and two months okay so there's
no daycare it's you're the
daycare yes okay um two and two months
okay and are you doing anything to bring
in additional I mean obviously you're
contributing big time to the household
are you doing anything
financially um we've looked at some
options but I am not a born salesperson
sure so selling from my house is not
really um a good option what about like
customer service something you could do
in the evening on the
phone we haven't I've kind of looked at
it briefly but I haven't really delt
into it too much I've never done
anything like that with my um yeah I've
never done that so and just to get
cleared I'm just I'm asking asking lots
of questions because I want to see this
situation your husband does he work like
crazy hours or is he kind of like 9
to5 UM at the moment he works from 7 to
3:30 um and then we're also a military
family so he's gone with that as well
okay and how often is he
gone um at least once a month for how
long um a weekend if he has to do more
training than could be up to a month
okay I'm just trying to get a picture of
the situation my first thought is like
okay you guys' income is super low and
when I see a super in low income my
first thought is how can we get it
higher so is he capped off in any way I
mean he's he's in the military is he
able to go out and do more work I see a
place for you to do more work um based
off the schedule and kind of what you
laid out um but I'm also wondering about
your
husband um right now he's trying to get
a promotion um to a different
position within uh the company he works
for if he does that then we'll be set if
he doesn't get it then we just can't
sustain this I'm just trying to figure
out um he would go from 36 to about 90
90 okay yeah that's a good quite the
promotion yes okay um it's a different
job entirely but it's within the same
Department
um
so but we won't really know anything if
he's going to get that job until either
March or April and what I feel is that
you guys are kind of waiting what I feel
is that we're kind of waiting we're
trying to figure out what to do but I'm
also trying to figure out how to not
have no money right and get to a point
if he doesn't get the job I don't want
to be just completely strapped I hear I
hear I see based on what you laid out a
house that's on fire like it's the
Flames are they're kissing kissing the
roof like it's it's on there but when I
asked about the urgency of earning
income I didn't sense the urgency it's
kind of like oh I looked in something
but I'm not a salesperson and he has
this but that and in a situation like
this if I'm being truly honest Sarah
like you guys don't have the ability to
sit on your hands whatsoever like when
you're in this situation it's like any
job's a good job any job's a good job
until I get the job right and I think
that's what you're going to have to
embrace is you're in a situation where
you're not earning enough to when I say
you're I mean you and your husband
collectively are not earning enough to
support your family thank goodness
you've got this $5,000 there but like
you said to your point you're going to
keep burning through that if we don't
today decide I'm going to get a job like
I'm going to get a job until I get the
job and for you that's why I'm asking
I'm like okay he's not working crazy if
he's home at 3:30 boy he's going right
back out going back right back kids and
go back out or you're going out
somebody's going to
work he's go coming back home and then
he's doing military stuff that's unpaid
okay then you're going to work when the
kids go to
sleep is he getting paid
overtime no so he's making 36 Grand
working over 40 hours a
week he well that no when he gets home
he's it's doing military stuff and
that's
listen something something about this
has to shake
loose something about this has to shake
loose what's left on this car
alone 11 I think this car can
go do you guys need two cars right
now yes because when he's gone I would
be without
transportation to like a doctor's
appointment grocery store can you come
go out once he's
home well like when he's gone
you know can we sell it and downgrade to
a 5,000 car wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute sorry I'm get I'm getting
frustrated here's
here's here's where we're at if you
whatever you look for you'll find all
right Sarah and right now I don't think
you want to find the solution I think
you want to go on Wick and I think you
want that to be the solution and it
doesn't matter what George your I says
for you what we're hearing back right
now is no that won't work and I can't do
that because of this and nope can't do
that listen then stay in
debt right what you if you don't want to
take any of the advice then the option
is I stay in debt and I go on Wick you
have to look at both sides of this
equation or you can Embrace doing
something very unconventional for you
very different very outside your Norm
very outside your comfort zone and then
you get to where you truly want to go
which is out of a stressful place with
money out of borrowing from your savings
every single month in order to make ends
meet but you have to be willing to
accept the solution George and I can
give Solutions till we're blue in the
face but if you don't want to actually
accept them and embrace the suck and
actually go out and do it then go on
Wick choice is yours maybe time to
embrace the suck or sell the house and
rent or sell the Caren make more money
if she had called in and we said well
Sarah there's nothing we can do for you
she would have been pissed at us but
instead we gave you a long laundry list
of choices you don't want to take them
listen we can only do so much this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
all right this is the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshot George camel to my right
we're your host today if you want to get
on the phone lines you have a question
that's burning in your soul you can ask
that question the number is 8825
5225 and uh you'll go to the phone
screener the wonderful Austin who will
make sure that you can come on here and
not talk crazy and so that's how that
works we trust him with our whole life J
do we trust Austin big time he does a
great great job all the guys in the
booth today they're all guys do an
excellent job keeping things up and
running and it's funny because you know
when calls come through George we can
see a little just like a little a
oneline summary snippet yeah of kind of
what they're going to be talking about
and our last call you know it was a a
young lady who they were just dealing
with the frustrations of a income that's
too low a core income that's too low
it's not sustainable and they had the
hope of a of ra on the horizon but what
is kind of far in the Horizon and so of
course they're worried like what do we
do maybe we have to go on Wick and so
George you and I kind of laid out what I
think were wonderful suggestions to not
have that be the case and what I want to
say about that is you know obviously if
you call this show we're going to give
you advice you're never going to call
this show and us go oh well there's
nothing you can do we're never going to
say that to you we're never going to say
your situation is hopeless we're never
going to tell you 's nothing that you
can do and well just depend on the
government you're never ever going to
get that answer from us so don't be
surprised when what we tell you to do
sounds a lot like work it's going to
sound a lot like you getting out of your
comfort zone it's going to sound a lot
like you embracing a different
philosophy possibly surrounding your
life and your money and listen get
excited about that because the option is
staying the way you were and so it leads
me George
to an observation that I've made and you
can see if sometimes you fall into this
Camp if you're listening but you know
sometimes people would rather be right
than happy oh well I always want to this
is what I secretly want to ask the
caller are you looking for confirmation
or do you actually want help she wants
to be right that there's I shouldn't say
this some callers want to be right that
there's no way out there's nothing to do
I get then be happy and embrace the fact
that we're giving you an answer that's
going to lead you to peacefulness more
happiness less stress like but you if
you'd rather be right that there's no
way out then be right well it's like
that that friend who likes to vent and
complain to you and I think the healthy
thing to ask that friend before they
start on one of their rants is go do you
want me to just listen or do you want
Solutions hey and if you just want me to
listen you vent that's fine yeah well
yeah okay we can waste some time but if
you're looking for Solutions I'll give
them to you if you're actually wanting
that yeah so I think that happens with
callers a lot and when I know they're
not going to take the advice Jade here's
when they I call it getting wailed cuz
they go whale and I go oh whatever
whatever's on the other side of that
well is going to be a justification an
excuse of why they can't and what
happened what riled you up is that we
just kept hitting wall after wall after
wall and I'm like these are things that
you and I have both done it's not even
hypothetical when we didn't have enough
money we just went and got more jobs
that's right and I think something you
know we can kind of hear it in your
calls I I love the book it's called
Never split the difference by Chris Foss
and it's about negotiating but he talks
about this concept that takes place when
you're negotiating with somebody where
they move from just saying yes yes I
know yes I know to that's right and what
happens is a lot of times you guys we
have folks call on the show and they're
kind of used to our our principles and
and maybe somewhere in their head
they're like yeah that's right I
probably should live on you know yes I
should live on less than my make or yeah
I should budget or you know yeah there
might be a way for me to do better in
this situation but when you you mentally
move to the point of that is right
not just me agreeing and going yes yes
yes yes but when you go that's right I
do need to get a job that's right I can
make a better use of my time that's
right I am being a little bit lazy that
is right that's when you start to see
that mental shift in that's huge because
you're accepting that this is the right
way to go forward and it's an accurate
depiction of what's going on as opposed
to you just going yeah yeah yeah because
that's basically well it's basically the
same thing George well a lot of people
Jade on the on these calls they'll paint
themselves into a corner and they'll go
well I have two crappy options it's
either I withdraw from my 401k or I stay
in debt forever or I move the debt
around I'm going there's option C and D
and E and F but they have a limited
vocabulary they only know the two
letters of the alphabet There's A and B
and so we we can't see it like that
there's so many more options out there
but you got to be willing you got to be
willing to amputate the Tahoe as Dave
said for 30 years and sell the car and
get the second job and maybe move to a
cheaper area or downgrade in house or
sell the house or maybe you go to work
and put the kids in daycare because you
can make more money doing that even if
it's not ideal it's almost like you know
you go you go to the doctor for your
checkup right and they're like listen
your triglycerides are high your
cholesterol is high if you don't change
your diet you're putting yourself at
risk for a heart attack or stroke and in
the moment you're like and they're
telling you all these things that you
can do to lower your cholesterol to
lower your you know to make yourself a
healthier person but in your mind you're
going oh man if I have to give up red
meat or man if I have to like pull back
on the salt intake and you're looking at
all the negatives and how it's going to
feel in a moment if you have to make
those adjustments and most of us we just
go away and go in the in the moment in
the doctor's office we're going yeah
yeah I know you know I need to I need to
do this but it's not until we hit that
like that moment you have that Health
scare you have that moment that you're
like oh my gosh he was right like that's
right I do need to make these changes
and so it's almost like George sometimes
people really do
um have to hit that Rock Bottom moment
or like we've call we call it here that
I've had it moment that it's like
listen back when you're ready back
really ready to change H Rock Bottom o
so good George good stuff and and let me
just say cuz I I just want to say this
if we ever um take some time and really
come back and talk about a situation or
we we you know we we had to give her a
little bit of tough love there we love
you guys like we we truly care about you
I'm never going to you know deliver the
paddle just out of fun it's truly I want
you to get this like I don't want her to
go on Wick I want her to get control of
her money and be able to look back on
this moment and go like that was the
Catalyst that was the moment that
changed everything and I want her to
come back here and be on the debt-free
stage like all of us just simply want
the best for you we want you to have a
stress-free life with your money we want
you to be able to live and give like no
one else we want you to be able to
experience the same peace that that we
experienced from walking through the
baby steps and changing our whole
perspective and how we view money we
want you to experience that so that's
what the show is all about don't ever
get it twisted and think well they're
just being mean or they're just yelling
at her it's never that and I hope that
you can see that um in our heart in the
way that comes across all right that's
it Katie in Kansas City Missouri we're
coming for you what's going on
Katie hi thanks for taking my call um so
my husband and I um have followed steps
and we are debt free we have um about a
million dollar saved yeah um we are
renting right now because we moved to a
different state and when we moved there
was nothing that we could find that we
wanted to um buy at the time and so
we're renting right now um we have the
opportunity to build a house on my mom's
property she actually gave us a portion
of her property and it's $500,000 is
what we would spend on building the
house we have five children um it's a
it's a 2,800 foot house um what's your
question just because we're up against
the clock I want to make sure we get
sorry get you help we were just
wondering if this is a good um Financial
Choice for us we're worried about how
it's going to affect our retirement why
would it affect your retirement to take
500k from the million to do the house
yeah how old are you
guys um 40
oh no you can't touch retirement is it
in a brokerage or is it in 401ks no so
half of it so 500,000 of it is in
retirement the other 500,000 is just in
um High interest savings and some mutual
funds and um stuff that we can that's
liquid was that earmarked for this
house oh kind of because we sold our
last house before we moved and so we
have that into a into an account that is
just earning interest right now listen
to if the money is liquid it's not
terrible it's not a terrible idea at all
most people's wealth is sparse between
you know their investment accounts and
their personal residents and you've got
plenty of time to build up more
retirement investing I would pay cash
for this place I would too and then just
yeah that's yeah that's what we're
planning to pay cash we're just
wondering if it's going to you don't
think that will affect go to an
investment calculator popping 500,000
that you have now plus all of the future
amount you're going to invest for the
next 20 years from 42 to 62 I think you
guys are going to be just fine
especially with no house payment ding
ding it's amazing $500,000 house in cash
wo that's something to be be excited
about this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
this is the ramsy show I'm your host
Jade warshot joined by George camel host
of the YouTube show the George camel
show and also author of the new book
Breaking Free from broke an honor to
host next to you George it's an honor to
be with you as well Jade awesome so
let's go to the phone lines where we've
got Leslie from Atlanta GA what's going
on
Leslie hi um well I wanted to say hi but
anyway I'm sorry I'm a housewife with
two kids and my husband works and makes
about
1,500 if he works Saturdays I also have
a mortgage another mortgage that I rent
out to my dad and to other renters okay
and and um I make about
2,900 in that in that house but the
mortgage in that house is um
1,300 and I just want to we also have a
car loan that is
375 monthly well how much is the whole
car
I huh how much do you owe on the entire
vehicle like what's the full
balance um 20 or 19,000 okay keep
going
and that was that was about it what's
your
question how can I help my husband like
save or how can we
invest in like a Roth R like I just want
to help him out okay um I think let me
go back right quick because I think I
missed the very first thing you said
when you said
$1,500 what was
that my husband that's what he makes
weekly per
week okay and talking six grand a month
you've got a primary residence which is
where you live and then you've got a
rental that you're renting out and then
you got the car note right so you have
two
mortgages yes sir okay so let's just get
some particulars here the rental what do
you owe on that like what's the
whole enchilada 5,000 for that other
house and the house that I'm staying at
right now is
60,000 to P for the mortgage okay that's
all you owe on it um and then you've
just got the car so what I hear and I
don't know if you meant this but it
sounds like you and your husband kind of
do your money
separately yes a little bit okay and it
sounds like you're saying how can I help
him save so can you tell me what his
debt is just for the sake of the
conversation like tell tell me about his
financial
snap he has no B at all okay so then
help me understand why you feel like
you're helping him save as opposed to I
want to I want us to save and have more
savings as a
family um because I because my debt is
well his debt is the house my debt is
the other house and the car and I just
want to get rid of all the payments but
I I need to like
I need help or guidance to how to how to
pay it off like
Fast Yeah okay or if I should even do
that the first I think the first thing
here is I really I mean how how long
have you guys been
married we've been married for three
years okay three years Now's the Time
for you guys to be like all right we've
been married for three years who knows
how long you were together before that
it's time to combine this thing you have
kids yes sir we have two kids so you
combin DNA but bank accounts is that
what I'm
hearing yeah it sounds crazy CU it's
kind of crazy is it a trust thing like
why did you guys keep them
separate no it's just we haven't really
talked about joining them together and
also um but why is that because you
talked about having
kids I think I know why I think it's
like I feel like you feel guilt about
the fact that you have and I'm just
using your words these are not my my
words I think you feel guilt over the
fact that you have car debt and you have
this rental debt but maybe because
you're not bringing in cash money that
you feel like okay maybe if I frame it
up in a way of I'm helping him does that
make sense that's kind of what I'm
hearing
here that's how I feel in a way because
it is a lot of money that I need to put
into other things it is but it's not
that listen it's debt but it's not like
you didn't call in here being like I've
got $100,000 and I've got all you know
this long laundry list of debts okay yes
you've got a $199,000 car yeah we
probably need to pay that off but what I
really want I'm thinking of sorry no
that's okay what I'm what I really want
is what we're getting to on this call is
really not the $19,000 of debt like
that's a problem and you can get that
paid off but what will really make this
easier is you both have to feel
comfortable to be who you are in the
marriage and who you are is somebody who
came in with debt who he is is somebody
who came in with Mortgage Debt who he is
is somebody who makes $6,000 which is a
great contribution to the home and who
you are as somebody who's a stay-at-home
mom with two kids who makes a great
contribution to the home do I think that
you could benefit maybe from going out
and getting some extra work and bringing
in some money absolutely but not to
claim a place of equality in the
marriage or a place to where now now
you're doing your part not in that sort
of way so I do think that you and your
husband probably need to have some
conversations of you know what what
would he say if you said listen I feel a
lot lot of guilt over the fact that I
have this debt and I kind of feel like
we're you know we have two separate
goals like you have your money I have my
money what could it look like for us to
combine what do you think he would say
if you said
that um he's really suppor is is just me
like I kind of don't want to put that
pressure on him I feel like it would be
a big pressure well how are you paying
for the car right
now with the rent money from the other
house so where does his money
go um to the to the house so if you got
rid of this rental you would have zero
dollars of income and you wouldn't be
able to pay your car
note yes sir and what would happen if
the money that he's bringing into the
household paid the car note or paid the
car off what would
happen um we actually talked about just
like um going month a month and paying
paying it off for just two years
years okay like we'll finish paying it
off in two years I think all of your
plans suck right now because you guys
are not aligned with your financial
goals I feel the same way he makes great
money you guys have money in
savings yes sir how much I don't know
how much he has but I have that's a
problem
Leslie that's a huge problem big problem
that you have no transparency you're an
accountability in this
marriage I would have a come to Jesus
meeting tonight and go I need to know
exactly what's happening with our
finances because it's our finances
because we decided to get married we
decided to have kids and I haven't done
a good job paying attention you own it
don't come accusatory just say I have
not done a good job and I own that and I
want to do better I want us to get on a
plan together I want us to pay off my
car loan I want us to pay off our
mortgage you got to change the pronouns
here if you're ever going to make
progress cuz you called in saying I want
him to retire sooner right that's a goal
that's a shared goal that hopefully you
both have the only way to do that is if
you work together and you combine
finances and you attack these goals
together with
intensity yeah because I look at this
and I go oh man like you guys your
situation financially it's not the it's
far from the worst I've ever seen let me
just put it like that I look at these
num just the numbers and I go oh wow if
they wanted to she could probably sell
this rental and whatever that brings
they could probably pay off their
Primary Home Mortgage and pay off their
car and you might have enough in savings
to pay off your car today you have no
idea yeah the thing is that um it's just
kind of my mom kind of gets in the way
she's like that that house has nothing
to do with your husband like
don't oh so she's saying keep your side
thing keep your side thing as a as a
fallback it's something that's there
that's the complete wrong way to enter
into a marriage which is I'm going to
keep this piece on the side just in case
that lets me know
that where I sit if you enter into
something like that it's do it's telling
me one or two things it's either telling
me they've given you a reason to create
that fallback like they've shown you
something that's made you feel like I
need to make sure I got mine on the side
just in case or you're carrying previous
baggage into it that's causing you to
react in that way neither which of is
good I would suggest that you guys sit
down with a good marriage counselor
because I think that this is this is not
a money problem like this is not a
numbers problem this is you feeling
secure in your marriage you feeling like
you can trust your husband him feeling
like he can trust you and you feeling
like you have a vote which you do yeah
you do o I want this sorted out please
listen better help is great I use them
my husband uses them you guys find a
marriage counselor and get this sorted
out this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
you're listening to the Ramsay show our
scripture and quote of the day 2
Corinthians 4:7 says this but we have
this treasure in Jars of Clay to show
that this all surpassing power is from
God and not from us Jordan Peterson said
work as hard as you possibly
can one at least on at least one thing
and see if it happens ooh that's perfect
that's the baby steps I like that work
as hard as you can at at least one thing
and see what happens love that Jordan
all right very very good all right
George I say we hit these phone lines
with a Vengeance let's go to ciss in
Myrtle Beach South Carolina what's going
on yes hello everybody thank you for
taking my call uh I am uh a new uh to
Ramsay uh listening to your podcast I
enjoy them very much I have now become
obsessed with trying to pay off my
primary mortgage cool I am I'm I'm
obsessed now and so
um uh my question is with regards
to my investing currently I'm my little
backstory I'm 56 years old okay uh I'm
single um uh I I do very you know my
income gross wise um between my uh
business and uh an investment property
that I do like short-term rentals is
upward about 300,000 that's gross okay
.99 so I have to pay my own taxes and I
pay into my uh insurances and I pay into
my uh retirements and things like that
okay
um I'm now finally out of credit card
debt I have no debt I uh my car is paid
off um I I have two mortgages of course
my investment property which which which
the income that I get more than pays uh
for everything required in that property
what's the mortgage on it
it's
186,000 cool and then I just built my
forever dream home um and my my my
uh property uh excuse me my mortgage
balances about 437,000
okay I don't want to be in my 70s still
paying a mortgage right how much are you
investing right
now I'm investing maybe about 10%
okay my gross Sal all right how much do
you have in your nest egg and investment
retirement accounts total it's over
500,000 okay right now um and you're
putting about 30,000 in roughly a year
annually yes sir
okay hey are you um are you living on a
budget what's that Aha and there lies
the problem because I'm looking at I'm
looking at you I'm like okay this is
this is a a boss Bab like she's doing
her thing making $300,000 a year she
bought her dream house for you know
$437 you got 500,000 in retirement like
there's certain things that you're
really really doing right but if you say
to me listen I'm 56 and I want this this
this house paid off I'm looking okay I'm
like you're on a $300,000 income what
would look like if you lived on
150 well you know 300 I think is what I
did in
2023 um so I didn't always always do
that but I'm this is what I'm doing and
I'm I'm probably it's probably going to
go up every year because you know my I'm
I'm you know my income will go up of
course well you're paying almost 100
Grand in taxes a year as
well um not not exactly that because you
know thankfully I have some good
business expenses and I write things off
for the uh from the property and and all
that stuff but I'm just wondering where
all of your net income is going yeah I
like to know that too I mean I think
there's some you're you're doing really
well on the investing side and savings
side but I think you're you're spending
a whole lot of money too I do too I will
agree with you I am having a good time
I'm not going to lie about that I mean I
do I do a lot of traveling um I play
golf twice a week I mean I'm having a
good time here good yeah and you should
have a good time but I also want to know
that your other goals are taken care of
first and so you're talking about
investing are you wanting to to pay off
the house faster by doing something
differently well so this was my my
thought process and this is why I'm
calling so um this is probably the most
uh in
2023 I I was floored when I opened up my
statement for my property management
company as to what the gross income was
on the property for 2023 so I'm very
happy about that um so I'm I'm just
wondering um I was thinking of just
every time the property management
company makes a deposit into my account
from a rental I just want to plug get
and pay the principal on my on my on my
primary mortgage okay and what's wrong
with
that well then I was also thinking
should I just in addition to that hold
off on my
retirement contrib I think you need to
up your retirement you make enough money
that you you're technically in what we
call Baby Steps four five and six baby
step four is you're investing 15% of
your income your gross income every
month okay and then five doesn't apply
to you but six is you're paying off your
home and so you should be able to do
both of those simultaneously and because
you have such a nice income you should
be able to do them both very well
simultaneously like you can do your 15%
and put a very nice decent chunk towards
paying off this Home Mortgage there's no
reason that you should retire with
either of these mortgages if you really
put the pedal to the metal and I mean if
you're depending on how intense you are
about this cuz when you called in you
said listen I'm obsessed with paying off
my primary mortgage are you obsessed to
the point of selling your
rental um that was a thought um that was
a thought because I figured let me let
me take the income from the rental and
at least pay half of it down uh because
my I probably have over $200,000 worth
of equity in the investment property
uhuh and and so the my my thinking was
let me just try to pay as much of this
down for the next few couple of years
and then it maybe sell my investment
property yeah and take the equity and
just pay off the rent why not what's
wrong with that what's wrong with you
taking and I think you should do again
this is not an excuse for not doing a
budget I still want you to do a budget
and see real numbers because just saying
listen I'm going to take this check and
pay that off that's great but you might
find in the budget that you have more
money to put with it and and it not
really affect your lifestyle all that
much and make some Headway faster you
know baby step six is all about being
very intentional you don't have to be
like scaled back on you know barely
living but you might do a budget and go
okay listen there's some money that's
getting P away and I I would rather use
it in this way to pay off the mortgage
you might find that and so taking those
rent checks and maybe a little bit more
money in adding it with it and maybe you
give yourself a two to three year
timeline and say I'm going to pay this
down for the next two to three years and
then at that point I'm going to sell
this and use the equity and have a
completely paid for primary mortgage and
then as you continue to age you might
decide that you want to Stack up some
more cash and buy another rental
completely in cash mm you got options
girlfriend I would not pause investing I
just did the math for you from 56 to 62
if you did nothing you just left the 500
Grand sitting there in good mutual funds
you'd have about 900,000 at 62 with a
10% return but if you invest 15% it'll
be closer to 1.3
million if you just diligently put away
15% every year into retirement accounts
and investment
accounts okay cuz right now I have a I
have a traditional and I have a Roth and
I guess with the rth because of my
income I can't really contribute too
much to the IRA um after tax to that yes
sir yeah the Roth IRA does have uh
income limits but you can do a backd
door Roth so I would connect with a
smartvestor pro at ramsy solutions.com
they can help you set that up you're
basically funding the traditional IRA
with after tax money and then converting
it
over yeah because that was my concern
because you know that about 500,000 is
is pre-tax sure well I wouldn't go
convert it all to Roth that's not wise
either too much that's too much that's
too much um because I have pay like
taxes and stuff like that right no I'm
not trying to I'm not trying to I just
want to make sure that 10 years from now
you can actually
retire so you don't once you're not
making 300 Grand I want your Investments
to make you 300 Grand that's a good re I
mean I will say this is probably a
banner year 2023 is a banner year for me
I've been you know and so I see it's
just going to it's just going to
continue um you know God willing for the
next a couple of years so while I am
here while I am in while you're making
this money you need to keep living like
you're making 100 Grand and that's how
you're going to make this money work for
you invest 15% knock out the mortgages
that's the game plan I would put that on
a four-year plan by the time you're 60
this thing has got a bow on it at the
birthday party y'all are sale Britain
mhm get the friends together I know
that's right paid off Home Mortgage we
gave you the way to get there it's up to
you to walk it out ooh George I enjoyed
hosting the show with you hey don't
forget we're going to be taking your
your questions in this every dooll Q&A
coming up 5:00 p.m. central Time on the
Ramsey Show YouTube channel don't miss
that's right we'll see you there this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
n